c'est dans l'île d'anticosti que l'on
trouve la plus forte densité de cerfs de
virginie au canada en l'absence de
prédateurs ces animaux se multiplient au
point où ils sont en train de brouter
toute la forêt qui leur sert d'abri et
de nourriture
il est le symbole de lille qui
l'habitent le cerf de virginie règne sur
la plus grande île du québec l'île
d'anticosti un territoire de 220
kilomètres de long au décor sauvage
étonnant les oiseaux fréquentes lille
mais pas de mammifères y ont élu
domicile
le cerf domine la forme d'anticosti
[Musique]
dans le village de port menier aucune
frayeur n'empêche le cerf de tenir le
rôle du compagnon aimable de la famille
parfois devenus presque domestique et on
n'a pas de coyote a même pas le droit
d'avoir un jardin des chevrets sont
vraiment protégé ici la population
respecte énormément les ar un animal qui
était plus mystique
mais quand on sort du village dans les
forêts de l'île le cerf de virginie
reste un animal sauvage
depuis 1976 denis pedneault et guide de
chasse dans l'île
[Musique]
son travail en fer témoins et des
déplacements des serres dans les bois
pour manger et s'abriter quand les
conditions sont propices ce territoire
offre des charges exceptionnelles le
chevreuil chelala moteur économique de
l'île d'arz que ce tir pour remercier
henri meunier de d'avoir la porte et les
chiffres ici
le français est propriétaire de
l'endroit henri meunier a eu le projet
fou de se créer une réserve personnelle
de chasse dans l'ide
à partir de 1896 il fait venir des
régions de l'île est cap chat et
probablement près de rimouski 200 cerfs
de virginie
le troupeau se multiplient rapidement
pour atteindre 200 mille bêtes et même
au delà
le cheptel devenu en surnombre à vite
manquer de nourriture
avec les années l'animal en est venu à
manger le sapin or les sapinières lui
servent d'abri l'hiver le cerf court à
sa perte en détruisant son habitat
le ch est vrai il ya besoin de
nourriture il ya besoin de couverts ci
ait pas de couverts de chevreuil en
hiver et marne
l'île d'anticosti représente l'extrême
nord de l'air de distribution du cerf
une limite artificielle créée par
l'homme
ici les hivers sont longs et rigoureux
le chercheur de l'université laval
steeve côté observent et étudient le
comportement du cerf de virginie
depuis 2001 les serbes vont avoir des
réserves pour passer une partie de
l'hiver et quand l'hiver traîne un peu
et quant au mois d'avril ont encore
plusieurs centimètres de neige au sol le
laissèrent en plus de réserve et c'est
là qu'on va voir une grande mortalité
à la fin des années 1920 les botanistes
marie victorin et roland germain sont
les premiers a mentionné l'impact du
cerf sur la végétation
ils écrivent les introductions
bouleversèrent profondément l'équilibré
de la flore et de la faune puis en 1953
le boulot de plus d'un mètre est rare le
cerisier de pennsylvanie est sûre
brouter le noisetier disparu
aujourd'hui on ne trouve plus d'érable à
hippies ou de cornouillers
les arbres feuillus et les arbustes
éliminés leseur s'écrivait en hiver des
ramilles et des bourgeons c'est là qu'il
s'est rabattu sur une nourriture
inhabituel pour un cerf le saper même en
été de mai à novembre ils broutent les
repousses qui sortent de terre
ce régime particulier à base de ceux
connus faire l'a éloigné biologiquement
de sa population souche il a fait de lui
un animal nettement plus petit que ses
cousins du continent de 30 à 50% moins
lourd mais il s'est adapté à son nouvel
environnement
donc être suggestifs par exemple qui est
beaucoup plus long par rapport à sa
grosseur il ya développé ces glandes
parotides pour détoxifier les produits
qui sont dans les conifères sont
beaucoup plus grosse par rapport à sam à
ce qu'annonçait donc toutes sortes de
petites choses qui ont changé qui font
que ce cercle est capable de se
maintenir sur ce régime là si on prenait
un ca de l'île est aujourd'hui on l'a
mené sur l'île évidemment ce serait
difficile
quand les serres ont débarqué dans l'île
la sapinière formaient le peuplement
dominant or aucune nouvelle sapinière ne
s'est établi dans l'île d'anticosti
depuis 1930 celles qui restent ont plus
de cent ans elles auront disparu avant
50 ans
en conséquence pour le cerf de virginie
d'anticosti passer l'hiver est un combat
pour la survie des dizaines de milliers
peuvent mourir de faim et d'épuisement
c'est particulièrement vrai du côté nord
de l'île avec ses escarpements et ses
quatre de plus de son maître
le côté nord des mortalités plus
difficile parce que plus de sapinières
ce côté nord la majorité du côté n'a pu
y ont de la misère à avoir accès à la
mer parce que à cause des cadres à la
fin de l'hiver affaibli et souffrent de
la faim auxerre est prêt à tout pour
quelques brins d'herbe
j'ai même vu des serres sur des
corniches bien qu'est ce qu'il fait là
et sur une corniche des caps de 200
pieds de roubles pilgrim sur les
corniches mais il pousse et douce
de repousses jeune fille de ita les lots
pour sow j'ai vu des chevreuils qui sont
morts pour aller chercher la nourriture
l'eau qui était sur les comme neige
2 - funeste pour ceux qui descendent
vers le sud de l'île avec son relief en
pente douce dès que le temps réchauffe
ils peuvent gagner la mer j'ai vu de
l'immigration de shanwei des passes
migratoires
on est assis à côté de ça cheuvreux qui
s'en vient qik est les territoires du
100% vire vers la mer puis utilise
beaucoup les coulisses culte et nal
calcaire ils suivent les lits de rivière
pilote descendent de descendre vers la
mer
il court vers les algues rejeté sur la
grève qui s'offre à eux comme une sorte
de nourriture je voyais à des foyers ont
la gueule pleine de laminaires comme ça
la majorité des biologistes disent qu'
aucun nutriment dans les mineures mais
moi je suis sceptique la deûle est là
dessus parce que je pense que ça peut
lui sauver la vie au printemps
quand la verdure et apparaît au
printemps et à l'été dans ses vieilles
prairies il trouve de quoi manger les
chats vrai on peut penser que dans un
champ ils vont manger des garmin est
comme son nom si plus les repos ce cadre
des p'tites ifs et qu'on ici sourit
manchots c'est du bonbon
[Musique]
quand tu arrives deux ou trois hiver
long et rigoureux consécutif il survient
un affaissement très importante du
cheptel souvent des baisses
spectaculaires
on peut parler de la moitié de la
population qui vont re
mais le cerf de virginie dans l'île
d'anticosti à la capacité de
reconstruire son troupeau rapidement le
savait capable de produire des jumeaux
c'est la danse qui diminua suite à des
travaux si l'on va avoir beaucoup de
familles qui vont produire des jumeaux
et vont commencer à se reproduire plus
tôt à l'âge d'un an et demi déjà donc là
ça va répondre est assez vite le dernier
inventaire aérien du ministère de la
faune réalisées en 2018 est publié en
2010 neuf noté une baisse importante de
80 % du cheptel de cerfs de virginie
résultat que le chercheur ne valide pas
d'emblée il n'y a pas d'autres la
population avait baissé probablement
moins que ce que ses chefs leur rapport
donc maintenant on est dans une
situation où la population a réaugmenté
et en 2021 on est dans une population
qui est beaucoup beaucoup plus abondante
que lorsque cet inventaire le eu lieu je
pense que les gens en général les
résidents les guides de chasse s'est
entendu sur cette question l'eau assez
facilement
[Musique]
pour denis pedneault aucun doute que le
cerf de virginie est revenu en force le
chevreuil est en montagne beaucoup de
serre il ya eu
a fait un très bon hiver moi je remarque
sultan ya du chevreuil les femmes elles
ont deux teams and j'ai vu trois
pour conserver sa réputation de
territoires de chasse d'exception
antique hausse et a besoin d'un troupeau
de cerfs de virginie abondant et en
santé
même si l'animal a démontré qu'il est
capable d'une grande résilience le statu
quo n'est pas envisageable
[Musique]
l'île d'anticosti situé en plein coeur
du golfe du saint laurent est presque
entièrement boisé une forêt transformer
en profondeur par la population du cerf
de virginie et l'exploitation forestière
depuis 1930 la sapinière à bouleau blanc
a presque disparu le problème avec la
coupe c'est que sara renner dans un type
d'habitat qui nie et qui est beaucoup
moins propice pour les soirs
depuis plus de 20 ans d expérience
d'aménagement sont menées dans plusieurs
parcelles de coupe
le ministère de la forêt et de la faune
planifie les travaux l'entreprise
forestière respecte la prescription
l'université laval est sur place
le chercheur steeve côté et de la
première heure
voici un exemple de zones aménagées l'ex
claude ullah khan à un espace clôturé et
contrôlée donc la stratégie
d'aménagement a été mise en place pour
recréer de l'hebdo à terme pour le cerf
de virginie surtout recréer de la
beatles love
en tout 190 kilomètres carrés ont été
aménagés depuis 20 ans pour empêcher une
trop grande densité de serre
après la coupe forestière on érige une
clôture en la déroulant sur des arbres
et branches et on laisse quelques arbres
semenciers comme le bouleau blanc et le
peuplier faux tremble leurs graines en
semences naturellement la zone protégée
et de petits îlots de forêt sont
préservés pour recréer un habitat divers
pour le sert une chasse sportive
supervisé à l'intérieur de l'espace
réduit l'intensité de serre ou
kilomètres carrés
après quatre ans les résultats sont
préliminaires mais visible et l'on
commence à voir des signes très
encourageants au niveau de la végétation
qu'on ne voyait pas de l'autre côté de
la clôture par exemple on a du boulot à
papier qui est rendu à m
11.5 de mètres maximum à certains
endroits on a apparition de framboise
qui a très très peu à l'extérieur autre
plante rarissime dans l'île les pilotes
à feuilles étroites honfleur une plante
bonbons pour le sert quand on apparition
de cette espèce là en bon bosquet comme
ça c'est un signe que la densité de
serre et beaucoup beaucoup plus faible
que la densité naturel sur l'île donc
pour nous c'est un signe encourageant
que on a réussi à le réduire la densité
dans cette ex coureurs et que la
régénération va pouvoir fonctionner
car à l'intérieur des exclus quelques sa
vie vivent toujours dispersés ici dans
l'espace clôturé de quatre kilomètres
carrés se casse pattes est une sorte de
barrière dissuasives pour empêcher les
serres d'en sortir ou d'autres d'y
entrer
quand on se penche un petit peu puis on
regarde au sol ben on va voir une
régénération de sapin baumier qui est
l'eau et qui est quand même abondante
avec des sapins qui pousse très vite
pays qui sont en bonne santé donc avec
une flèche terminal qui pousse bien tout
sur ce qu'on verra jamais non plus à
l'extérieur des expos pour plus de
succès en plus des repousses naturel on
a planté à l'intérieur des clôtures
après la coupe de petits sapins le sol
en est couvert donc dès que les sapins
commence à pousser un peu dans une
ouverture les chevreuils évidemment les
savons les voir et vont commencer à
faire du groupe mr donc on n'aura pas de
grandes flèches terminal comme on voit
ici les soeurs vont tout de suite
s'occuper de ces sapins lots en jeu au
large
pour bien documenté la survie des
repousses de sap est à l'extérieur des
espaces clôturé l'équipe de steve côté
on a marqué plusieurs milliers et les a
suivis pendant une longue période
on s'est rendu compte qu'après une
dizaine d'années environ presque la
totalité des cinq mille 5000 étaient des
joueurs étaient tous goûtés et notamment
le repeuplement de la zone protégée est
quant à lui en bonne forme mais pour
être efficace la stratégie est à long
terme voyez les sapins et marc est en
mode juge nous présentement donc il faut
ôter le temps de pousser pour atteindre
au moins deux mètres et demi de hauteur
avant de pouvoir enlever la clôture
parce que sinon les sarments revenez et
vont les brouter et tout ce travail et
leur avoir été fait pour rien
la nourriture est bonne et abondante
mais pour le moment l'ex claude dulac
anna n'est qu'un paradis d'été si on
imagine sa en janvier quand tu vas avoir
1 2 mètre de neige au sol la seule
nourriture disponible qui vont rester
vont être dans les lots de forêt
résiduelles avec les arbres qui vont
tomber et la pluie de revenir ici va
peut-être avoir des boulots qui dépasse
de quelques centimètres mais ça va être
un très mauvaise habitude hiver encore
pour plusieurs années
[Musique]
il faut être patient avant de déclarer
et si l'ex clos du lac supérieur a été
aménagé il ya un peu plus de dix ans et
le travail n'est pas fini
par exemple aucun signe de brut sur le
sapin et mais on va en voir sur le
boulot donc voyez s'il est le boulot là
était quand même brouter passablement
mais va très bien que ce qui indique que
oui ça si et de la régénération mais il
ya quand même un certain nombre de cerfs
incarnant cette action est
une des premières expériences à l'île
d'anticosti est le secteur du lac simone
les arbres ont été abattus en 2001 une
clôture a été érigé et maintenu en place
jusqu'en 2016 ou et alex clos a été
déclenché sur et parce que les sapins
ont atteint une hauteur qui est
suffisament on s'attaquait lessard ne
peuvent plus atteindre la flèche
terminal donc à ce moment à l'eau mais
monsieur du brut mais sur les sur les
feuilles sur les branches latérales les
arbres peuvent quand même survivre à
l'hiver
lessard contre ils ressortent de cette
ancienne zone fermée
ils ont de la nourriture et un abri du
verre
à l'aide d'une caméra de surveillance
les chercheurs mesure la fréquentation
des animaux score trop jusqu'à
maintenant c'est qu'il ya une espèce de
d'atterir pour l'ex clos une fois que
les clôtures sont enlevés parce que le
milieu est tellement différent de
l'extérieur et l'on ne beaucoup de serre
mais après trois heures environ et là on
commence à avoir des jeux une diminution
est plus haut on évolue dans le temps on
se rapproche des fréquentations qui sont
semblables à ce qu'on peut avoir l
extérieur
on compare l'habituellement de plus que
vint cerf par kilomètre carré le calme
et si on est dans une situation on est
probablement en haut de cette densité là
ici dont l'oci un ex claude dulac claude
d'écloserie en 2018
steeve côté remarque les indices que les
cerfs sont réapparus rapidement on voit
sur les branches latérales des signes de
brut mais relativement important par le
niveau réel bon nombre de ceux
présentement qui vont voter du sapin
divers mais qui peuvent aussi brut et
les branches le du boulot jusqu'à
jusqu'à ce que la hauteur que la neige
peut porter la masse des singes
[Musique]
un cerf de virginie avec une abondance
de nourriture et des abris survivra à
l'hiver de plus l'expérience prouve
qu'il peut devenir aussi imposant que
celui qui vit sur le continent ça
produit nécessaire qui sont pratiquement
qui peuvent aller jusqu'à deux fois plus
gros que ceux à l'extérieur donc elles
ont encore la capacité
de nippes et d'un guide de chasse
peut-on témoigner on a chassé dans les
enclos ou lol aujourd'hui sont ouverts
le chef
non seulement la qualité des serres est
vraiment à bonn parce que on recommence
à abattre des chaires de 200 ha li est
plus la nourriture et l or les travaux
d'aménagement démontre avec les années
que les efforts ne sont pas vains la
preuve saute aux yeux dans ce secteur de
coupe laissé à lui même depuis 20 ans il
a pris l'apparence selon le chercheur
d'une forêt parc
ça peut prendre très longtemps on peut
avoir une place hier mais on peut aussi
avoir une forêt très ouvert peu
productive avec juste des fougères et
des graminées ça peut rester comme cela
pendant des dizaines d'années
le contrôle de l'habitat du cerf de
virginie assure sa survie mais aussi
celle de la forêt les travaux
d'aménagement en cours ne couvre qu'une
petite fraction du territoire mais
semblent concluants
il ya eu des expériences sont différents
types de coupes dans les années 90 où on
pouvait essayer de régénérer les beatles
sans faire de clôture mais toutes ces
expériences lui ont donné des
conclusions négatives donc pour
l'instant la stratégie des ex clos est
la seule qui est capable de montrer un
effet à long terme
à force de travail et de faire des
recherches là dessus ils sont arrivés à
très très bons résultats avec les ans à
tlo
aujourd'hui il semble y avoir consensus
entre québec les chercheurs et l'île
d'anticosti quant à la manière de sauver
le cerf de virginie
si la stratégie qu'on veut pour les
nantis castille c'est de maintenir une
densité relativement élevé pour avoir
ton maintenir la qualité d'un produit de
chasse qui est reconnu partout sur la
planète il faut être capable de
régénérer l'habitude du verdus sport et
pour faire ça et présentement on connaît
pas de façon naturelle de far so
moi
[Musique]